how and why did you make a choice to be
a bright light
optimistic how did you decide to do the
performance the way you did it's one of
the most beautiful performances I've
ever seen and I've never seen choices
made like it in the genre Charlie is
like a lighthouse at sea he's he's he's
he's a bright light in a dark space he
lives in a two-bedroom apartment his
visitors are a few sadly he's been
harming himself by overeating for too
long and his health is compromised he's
made life choices that he finds himself
regretting knowing his very little time
left on paper five days
and the Epiphany he has is if I don't
reconnect with my daughter if I don't
make amends with my prior transgressions
then
it's purposeless and the only way that
he can do that is approach it with
optimism I wish that your character was
real